Ta-da!
Hi, It's N-ko!
Every Friday at this time, I will bring you The N-ko Show.
I plan to bring you my recommendations on Anime and movies,
anime quiz segments,
Q & A segments,
my monologue,
and other contents based on my personal preferences.
I will do my best to make this into a show
where you can easily learn the charms of anime,
whether you're commuting, or getting ready for bed during your busy life.
Of course, I will be sharing the latest Netflix shows' information as well,
so please check in every week.
Now, let's start "The N-ko Show"!
Weekly favorites!
This is a segment where I share anime and movies.
My recommendations are based on my personal preference.
I will categorize them into different themes.
My first show's theme is this...
You should binge-watch!
Anime series you just can't wait to see more of!
My recommendation for the first anime to binge-watch is this!
THE PROMISED NEVERLAND.
This is an anime
about boys and girls
who live at this certain facility,
but it's a facility full of mysteries.
This is a mystery anime,
so you just can't wait to see what happens next!
You feel eager to solve the mystery as soon as possible!
You want the leading characters to survive
more than anything.
You just want to cheer them on in this anime.
Please watch.
Up next!
RE: ZERO -STARTING LIFE IN ANOTHER WORLD-.
This anime is super, super, scary and full of suspense,
but you just can't stop wanting more!
I wanted protagonist Subaru Natsuki to find happiness while I was watching this show.
Subaru Natsuki has an ability called "Return to Death,"
and he experiences several painful deaths.
But he still continues to eagerly protect his loved ones.
This anime portrays Subaru Natsuki's passionate side.
And don't be satisfied just watching it once.
You will find something new
on your second and third viewing,
so I'd like you to binge-watch it several times!
The next anime is this...
ATTACK ON TITAN.
It's one foreshadowing after another.
Numerous mysteries are embedded in the storyline,
such as mysteries of the Titans, mysteries of the world,
mysteries of lineage, and mystery of incidence.
Soon as they're solved, another mystery arises.
When you binge-watch the whole series,
you can watch the mysteries unravel
along with Eren's maturing process.
So you can immerse yourself while watching this show.
Anyhow, it's packed with a massive amount of information.
All the way to the final season,
I recommend you to watch every season.
The next is
CODE GEASS: LELOUCH OF THE REBELLION.
It includes season two as well.
This series
has lots of information to cover as well.
Several countries are involved,
and it has numerous characters.
People of different lineages appear,
making its outlook very complicated.
I would like you to watch it with your full attention.
I would like you to immerse yourself in this world,
learning the settings and the story's history,
while enjoying each character and their relationships.
Each episode unfolds important elements as the story develops.
There's even an event where you'll constantly say, "What? Don't end now!"
This is a series that compels you to click "Next Episode."
The last one is this.
DEVILMAN CRYBABY.
This is my absolute favorite anime!
This is the anime that segued my working for Netflix.
In other words, this is a very important anime for me.
However, it's very dark and grotesque,
even from episode one.
I recommend preparing yourself prior to watching it.
After I binge-watched it, I became somber.
It's a unique anime packed with
the charms of Go Nagai's manga,
and director Masaaki Yuasa's perspectives.
It's just 10 episodes, so you can watch it fast.
Binge-watching it is highly recommended.
You'll finish watching today's recommendations quickly.
You'll be curious about what happens next,
so please watch them.
That's it for my weekly favorites!
N-ko English.
In this segment, I will share how to say anime quotes in English.
Let's learn to say anime quotes in English,
when you want to say the anime quote in English in your daily life,
or when you have an opportunity to befriend an anime fan abroad.
This is today's quote.
"You've crossed a line you shouldn't have crossed."
You've crossed a line you shouldn't have crossed.
This is one of the popular quotes from BAKI.
Let's remember it for when you have a chance to use it!
A little tip on pronunciation...
Put an emphasis on "crossed" when you say it.
Everyone, let's use quotations in your daily life!
N-ko's Q & A section!
As the name suggests, this is a segment where you can ask me any question,
as a VTuber and an employee of Netflix.
Please post your questions on Twitter or my YouTube channel comments.
So ask away!
Now, I'll start answering your questions!
Here's the first question.
What is your favorite animal?
I like the cheetah!
You might ask, "It's not sheep?"
But cheetah is just so cool,
it's an animal that represents my ideal woman.
She-cheetahs hunt, raise their cubs,
and yet they are the fastest animal. That is so cool!
I also love cheetah's beautiful legs and form!
Here's the next question.
What foods do you dislike?
I don't dislike any particular foods,
but I do have an allergy.
I'm allergic to yam.
That's why whenever I go to Osaka.
I have to ask the servers,
"Excuse me, do you use yam in this?"
I have to do that every time.
If yam is among the ingredients, I order Yakisoba instead.
Here is the next question.
Which do you prefer, aquarium or zoo?
If I had to choose one,
I prefer aquarium.
It's because the aquarium is open not just on sunny days,
but on rainy days too, both day and night.
It could be enjoyed at any time!
The aquarium is a popular dating spot too,
so I'd like to go on a date while watching beautiful jellyfish.
Here is the last question.
Where do you want to go the most right now?
I would like to go to Europe.
I've never been there,
so I'd like to go to the parts of Europe with beautiful ocean views.
Thank you for all your questions!
I look forward to receiving questions from my current viewers!
That's it for N-ko's Q & A.
So this is how "The N-ko Show" goes.
Everyone, how did you like it?
I'd love it if you found it informative and fun.
I'll be submitting "The N-ko Show" next week at the same time.
If you thought "It's fun!" or "It's cute!",
please subscribe and like the channel!
Let's meet again next time! See you.